quand gérard brémond il est président de
france à sa santé bonjour à vous merci
de réagir en direct sur arte france
une journée d'action nationale avec des
échauffourées des débordements des
tensions des violences à paris du côté
des invalides comment vous réagissez
malheureusement on pouvait s'attendre
c'est violent cela et que certainement
aujourd'hui ce mode de manifestations et
de revendications ne sont plus adaptées
à l'enjeu des problèmes qui sont devant
nous dans le système de santé
effectivement pour nous représentants de
l'ensemble des usagers de la santé
la revalorisation des salaires de
l'ensemble de ceux qui les soignent mais
n'est même pas une question c'est une
évidence même
par contre ce qui nous paraît important
aujourd'hui c'est comment nous redonnons
du sens à l'ensemble des professions
médicales dans une refonte totale de
notre système de santé qui doit se
fonder sur l'humanisme sur les attentes
et les besoins de ceux qui souffrent on
ait du sens aux métiers que sont les
métiers de soignants et la seule
thématique sur les métiers de la santé
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui que ce
genre de manifestation là ne correspond
plus du tout à des attentes et des
besoins de notre système de santé
malheureusement on ne peut que déplorer
c'est ces groupuscules qui viennent se
greffer à des revendications tout à fait
légitime de l'ensemble des soignants
mais qui effectivement générés et crise
sociale
quand vous dites que c'est plus possible
aujourd'hui de faire entendre sa voix de
cette manière cela vous surprend pas du
tout
je prends pas parce que depuis depuis
longtemps combien c'est difficile de
faire entendre nos effectivement des
revendications catégorielles ou sociales
terribles comme on a pu les mener
je crois que nous sommes arrivés au bout
d'un système là la crise e.coli 10,9 l'a
parfaitement bien démontrer a été un
révélateur est un accélérateur des
mesures nécessaires en profondeur de
notre société
comment retourner de la démocratie
puissance dans notre système de santé
reconnaître la valeur de ce qu'ils sont
des acteurs de ce système de santé et et
donner beaucoup plus de responsabilités
aux acteurs que ce stock sociaux le
terrain qui seront plus proches dé
soigner
y compris d'ailleurs les soigner et les
sommets au plus profond
pour nous ce qui est important c'est de
véritablement mettre en oeuvre une
démocratie de l'ensemble des soignants
et des acteurs de la santé sur des
territoires données pour pouvoir
répondre aux attentes et aux besoins des
patients redonner du sens aux métiers
aux métiers de la santé
c'est plus important mais et des
certainement revaloriser l'ensemble des
salariés qui sont dans le domaine de la
santé
le c ur de la santé et qui débouchera
effectivement encore d'habitude je
quelques mesurettes qui ne rouvriront
pas effectivement les énormes besoins
il faut que peu profité peut-être de
cette réflexion là pour entamer une
véritable réforme de fond de
l'organisation de notre système de santé
et donner la responsabilité à ceux qui
soignent pas simplement aux
administratifs et pour faire mieux le
système de santé descendants jacobins de
paris jusqu'au jusque sur les
territoires mais bientôt mais bien plus
les verts sz
c'est à dire les territoires ceux qui
sont acteurs au plus proche des besoins
et des attentes de ceux qui souffrent
les patients et faire remonter
effectivement ses attentes et ses
besoins
donc il ya une nécessité à ce que tout
le monde fasse mais recule pas ce même
problème notable est le reflet
6 renversé vers la gouvernance ce
système nous sommes des ces
manifestations la montre l'exaspération
d'un corps médical qui a été extrêmement
courageuse et est magnifique le tome 2
de cet oxyde ducrocq vide mais qui
demande à être entendu pour ce qu'il est
et pour les services opérant dans la
société
est ce que vous vous craignez vous qu'il
y ait des amalgames
quand on voit ce type de deux heures
lors de cette manifestation des
personnels soignants on sait qu'on est
dans un contexte international un peu
particulier en france c'est le cas aussi
avec les dénonciations de violences
policières présumées de racisme
présumées au sein des forces de l'ordre
vous craignez des amalgames de la
récupération de récupération et de me
regarde par les groupes politiques
mais effectivement cette situation est
éminemment politique on voit bien
aujourd'hui que un autre notre
démocratie de la représentation est mise
en difficulté et que il nous faut
réfléchir d'une façon là aussi posé mes
quatre mois ces événements on peut
s'interroger comment on peut réfléchir
une façon posée responsables à trouver
une démocratie plus participative où
chacun pourra se sentir beaucoup plus
participatif à la création d'un nouveau
système
c'est une démarche nouvelle qui nous
faut mener effectivement ça passe par
des tensions qui sont inquiétés de jeu
je pense pour bon nombre de personnes
qui sont favorables à ce que la
démocratie continue en sus pays et
comment on fait aujourd'hui
si on ne manifeste pas si on ne va pas
le pavé dans la rue pour revendiquer des
mesures du changement comment est ce
qu'on fait pour faire entendre sa voix
ou aujourd'hui vous parler démocratie
participative ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on entend d'ailleurs cette arme
et les deux peuvent être ouverts parce
qu'effectivement la la la manifestation
publique peut montrer une certaine
revendications mais à côté de la
revendication public il faut être une
capacité de pouvoir solliciter des
réunions des rencontres pouvoir
travailler et on a bien vu par le passé
après des manifestations
les responsables qu'ils soient syndicaux
ou institutionnels se mettre autour
d'une table et réfléchir vous trouver
des solutions et je pense que
effectivement l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre
et si on reste dans la tension et dans
la violence on n'arrivera pas à
construire quelque chose de consensuel
et depuis il permettra l'expression de
l'ensemble des parties c'est ça qui nous
inquiète donc il faut savoir mener les
deux manifesté revendiqué avec des
moyens qui sont les nôtres en restant le
plus dans la loi aussi le guen a tenu
mais aussi être en capacité de pouvoir
se mettre autour d'une table et de
pouvoir faire progresser notre système
de santé dans l'intérêt de tous
particulièrement l'intérêt des soignants
et l'intérêt de sonner